[Musik]
guten tag am 26 11 2010 stand die welt
der wissenschaft unter schock und nicht
nur sie denn an diesem tag verkündete
ein chinesischer forscher die ersten
genetisch edierten menschen der
geschichte geschaffen zu haben
im rahmen einer künstlichen befruchtung
sei das erbgut von zwillingen so
verändert worden dass die neugeborenen
mädchen fortan immun gegen hiv seien
würden eine sensation ein tabubruch
vielleicht sogar ein frevel und nur ein
beispiel für die enormen möglichkeiten
die sich mit den fortschritten der
gentechnik der zeit ergeben
ich bin sehr froh über diesen extrem
relevanten themen kreis mit zwei
ausgewiesenen experten sprechen zu
können den paläogenetiker svante pääbo
der mit seinem leipziger team das genom
des neandertalers rekonstruiert hat
sowie der zürcher kritikerin und
philosophien er fiel bei jena herzlich
willkommen frau war jena wie haben sie
denn diese grenzüberschreitung diesen
tabubruch wahrgenommen wie haben sie
davon erfahren und vor allem wie
schätzen sie ihn ein
ich habe auf twitter davon erfahren
heutzutage eine wichtige
informationsquelle für mich ich habe mir
zufällig gerade nachrichten zum human
genom editing summit in hongkong
angeschaut und war sehr überrascht
mit sowas hätte ich nicht gerechnet habe
noch ist nicht erwiesen ob seine
behauptung stimmt und das tatsächlich
geschehen ist
da gibt es noch einige fragen genau aber
wenn das wirklich so war bin ich echt
schockiert
solche eingriffe ins erbgut wurden breit
diskutiert und ich ging davon aus dass
man aufgrund der bestehenden richtlinien
vorsichtig vorgehen würde
aber das beispiel zeigt dass sich ein
einzelner über die richtlinien und
vereinbarungen hinwegsetzen konnte
erfreulicherweise waren sich viele in
der wissenschaftsgemeinde darüber einig
dass das schockierend ist ein aufruhr
ein schock sie haben ein forscherleben
der entzifferung des genoms des menschen
und seiner vorfahren gebet mit wenigen
sie diese maßnahme war menschen
genetisch in der keimbahn zu
manipulieren
ja ich denke ich war genauso geschockt
wie fast alle anderen lieder von gehört
haben
natürlich hat man fast befürchtet
odewald dass irgendwo auf der welt
irgendetwas man sowas passiert und jetzt
ist es wahrscheinlich dann passiert habe
ich nehme sozusagen hoffnung von der
fakt dass alle eigentlich dagegen sind
das sogar die ohne in changchun in china
wo das angeblich passiert ist nun
abstand nehmen und ist es auch
man kann ja sagen ein schock ich
verstehe dass andererseits sie deuten es
an war es doch nach der wahrnehmung
vieler nur noch eine frage der zeit bis
irgendjemand voranpreschen würde und
sagen das was technisch möglich ist das
mache ich jetzt auch was natürlich ein
problem
allgemein ende und es ist auch eine
technologie die nicht sehr aufwendig ist
wenn man die labortechnische
voraussetzungen haben das ist nicht so
wie eine atombombe zu bauen
die möglichkeiten sind da man wusste
dass es gibt einen rechtlichen rahmen
und er gibt es denn überhaupt wie ist
denn das gibt es global verbindliche
regeln regeln für den umgang mit dem
menschlichen genom es gibt in erster
linie die nationalen gesetze viele
länder darunter auch china wo das
passiert ist canon regeln die so etwas
verbieten
es sollte also eigentlich nicht
geschehen
darüber hinaus gibt es globale
übereinkommen unter wissenschaftlern die
aber keine rechtsverbindlichkeit haben
unter wissenschaftlern weil man sich
einig die nächsten schritte gut
abzuwägen
experimente mit menschlichen embryos die
ausgetragen würden gehörten sicher nicht
zur vereinbarung nach dem ersten gipfel
natürlich hat das nicht den status von
völkerrecht gibt auch keine sanktionen
und die man jetzt nachgeben könnte nein
die erfolgen auf grundlage von
nationalen gesetzen
aber es gab eine internationale
übereinkunft wie wir uns als
wissenschaftler zu verhalten haben
wir haben nun gesehen dass diese
vereinbarung ein solches ereignis nicht
verhindern konnte sie sagt es ja die
technologie ist da sie verglichen das
selbst mit der atombombe oder dem atom
spaltung jetzt könnte man sagen dafür
gibt es internationale behörden die
global überwachen was in diesem bereich
geschieht warum gibt es das nicht für
genetische manipulation das vielleicht
eine gute frage ich denke es gibt auch
diejenige konzerns vielleicht sogar über
was wir gedenken war es wünschte typ
unsere experimenten sollte man verbieten
oder nicht es gibt ja für einkommen über
biologische waffen zum beispiel wo es
mehr von dem konzern das es gibt
als solche sachen wie wir jetzt
besprechen und trotzdem behauptet wird
es hätte einen vorteil
es wird ja oft eine formulierung bemüht
da spiele jemand gott und das hat schon
eine wertung in sich wer das nicht
richtiger zu sagen da spielt jemand
evolution weil zum beispiel die
immunität die diese beiden kinder nun in
sich tragen ist eine die auch natürlich
vorkommt die also auch in der evolution
schon entstanden ist klingt doch ganz
anders da spielt jemand evolution als
gott oder
ja ich will doppel dossier vorsichtig
sein ich denke wie verstehen so
unglaublich wenig von der evolution
ja es gibt menschen die eine edition
einen verlust von datei von dieses gehen
die jetzt modifiziert worden und dies
sind resistent gegen hiv-infektionen das
ist wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht genau
dieselbe der lektion die man jetzt
eingefügt habe würde ich worte und wir
wissen auch dass dieses gehen irgendwie
hand die in der evolution und gibt bei
menschenaffen und menschen es hat
sicherlich auch irgendeine funktion die
wir noch nicht verstehen
also ich denke wir überschätzen uns
unglaublich wie denken wir können die
revolutionäre die verbesserten
vorantreiben
es ist ja schon mal eingriff der in der
weise enormes dass diese kinder sollten
sie selber kinder haben dieses gehen
jetzt weiter tragen geben weitergeben
kann
es gibt eine gefahr dass man die
komplexität nicht über schaut welche
gefahren sehen sie denn insgesamt noch
bei solch einem eingriff die beiden
mädchen werden dadurch vielleicht
anderen gefahren ausgesetzt wie wir
gerade gehört haben wissen wir beim
überschreiben oder wie in diesem fall
beim ausschalten bestimmte gen sequenzen
nicht welche auf target effekte daraus
resultieren mit anderen gehen
interagieren
das wissen wir nicht es gibt keine daten
zur sicherheit meine unmittelbar größte
sorge betrifft die weiteren
gesundheitsfolgen für diese mädchen um
die es hier geht
liebst der frage der evolution und was
sie an ihre kinder weitergeben was mit
diesen beiden geschieht wirft immense
ethische fragen auf
seit jahren gilt in der forschung tätig
dass man menschen nicht benutzt und
keinen unnötigen risiken aussetzt hier
haben wir eine situation wo wir die
risiken nicht kennen
das wäre mein erstes problem in einem
zweiten schritt geht es um die frage der
nächsten generation die kinder dieser
mädchen also auch da sind wir nicht in
der lage vorauszusehen wie groß die
risiken sind und das beunruhigt mich
sehr jetzt ist dieser tabubruch in china
geschehen einem land das sehr gut
überwacht ist bei dem auch der staat
weiß was die wissenschaftler tun für wie
glaubwürdig halten sie denn die
bekenntnisse des chinesischen staates
von diesem experiment nichts oder wenig
gewusst zu haben und es ist auch gerne
verhindert zu haben
die frage mich kann ich eigentlich nicht
einschätzen
vielleicht unterschätzen wir auch ein
bisschen wie gut meine bewacht ist in
china so was ich verstanden habe
gerüchteweise hat diese vor schwer sich
beurlaubt und zu sagen das ist außerhalb
der uni oder seine neue tätigkeit
gemacht so ich weiß nicht könnte man
sogar sagen wir sollten diesen man
dankbar sein weil dadurch diesen
tabubruch jetzt ein thema erzeugt hat
dass wir intensiver diskutieren
als wir es sonst diskutiert hätten dass
das aus der latenz in das explizite
gezogen hat das möchte ich ihm nicht
zugute halten
es gab durchaus eine debatte zu diesem
wichtigen thema es ist nicht aus dem
nichts aufgetaucht
die diskussion verlief in der gebotenen
haltung ohne zeitdruck aufmerksam und
konzentrieren sich in einer
extremsituation läuft die diskussion
anders
angesichts eines skandals fehlt
plötzlich die zeit für überlegte
antworten ich wäre die sache viel lieber
wie vorher angegangen zu diskutieren
nachzudenken argumente zu präsentieren
vorhandene unterschiede auszuloten und
zu bereinigen um am schluss ein resultat
zu haben mit dem wir alle leben und
weiter forschen können
wieso sagen diese diskussion ist
stattgefunden ich sagte wir haben
eigentlich vereinbarungen und jetzt geht
man hin und machen was dagegen also
wieso wir jetzt beide ein wort verwendet
das nicht hellhörig werden lässt das
wort wer ist denn eigentlich dieses wir
ist dass die gemeinschaft der forscher
sind dass die staaten ist das eine
weltgemeinschaft die überhaupt ein bier
ist oder besteht das problem hier gerade
darin dass es dieses einheitliche wir
gar nicht gibt
ich habe das gefühl dass in diesem
gebiet gibt es eigentlich ein konsens
zwischen forschung und gesellschaft und
gesetz gebe ländern starten und ich
denke dass andere sich diese vorbildlich
voran getrieben von den erfinderinnen
und ist ja ne verdiener ist zum beispiel
jemals ein paar kleine von den mittel
finden sind diese technologien und sie
lieben wird sehr viel von ihrer zeit für
diese ethische diskussionen
ich bin völlig einverstanden mit wir
meine ich gemeinhin meine kollegen in
der bioethik und politik in diesem fall
aber erfuhr dass wir eine erweiterung
bioethiker haben mit forschen wie
jennifer partner und mit
patientenvereinigungen
zusammengearbeitet die hilfreiche
technologien durchaus unterstützten und
sich in die diskussionen über das
weitere vorgehen einbringen wollten in
diesem fall gefiel mir dieses erweiterte
wir mike batt expanded denn nur so
finden wir einen weg mit dem wir alle
leben können
die technologie die diesen eingriff
möglich gemacht hat ist relativ jung
erst einige jahre alter ist christa und
bin hier öffnet sich ein
möglichkeitsraum der eigentlich schwer
zu übersehen ist wie das genau
funktioniert mit dieser gen schere
christa das schauen wir zu einem kurzen
film an
und so funktionierts christa zuerst wird
ein dna abschnitt bestimmt an dem die
gehen schere ansetzen soll
die schere wird dann so programmiert
dass sie genau diesen abschnitt findet
hat sie ihn gefunden wird der strang
durchgeschnitten und ein natürlicher
reparaturmechanismus verbindet die
beiden stränge das gehen wird
funktionsunfähig aber das erbgut bleibt
intakt so kann ein defektes gen
ausgeschaltet werden mit dem gleichen
verfahren können gene aber auch ersetzt
werden
eine große chance dieser neuen forschung
die vererbung einer krankheit kann so
verhindert werden
ja also eine gen schere die an etwas
einsetzt was wir ja auch ein modell
haben
der stoff aus dem wir alle gemacht sind
das genetische grundlage des menschen
das genom also da wird an gewissen
stellen ein schnitt vollzogen etwas
eliminiert was auch wieder hin zu
gesetzt werden kann verstehe ich das
richtig
ja so diese christel schneidet dann ein
oder zwei sternen
wenn man das nur so macht zeigt man eine
religion wie wir sagen ein stück wild
verloren wir wollen und dann das das ist
ein weg an gehen zb auszuschalten und
das ist was mit dieser sozial 5 gehen in
china jetzt gemacht wurde was man auch
machen kann ist dass man in dieser
prozess gibt man auf synthetische dna
stücke die man im labor center gesicht
hat dazu wir eine etwas andere sex haben
und die werden dann verwendet um diesen
beruf zu reparieren und so kann man eine
neue mutation hineinfühlen man kann eine
solche buchstaben in den genetischen
code zu hören mit einem anderen ersetzen
davon gibt es jetzt im menschlichen
genom 3 milliarden wenn ich richtig
informiert bin unglaublich komplex wir
kennen die wechselwirkungen nicht der
aufschrei ist jetzt groß am menschlichen
genome tatsächlich wird das aber schon
bei tieren und auch bei pflanzen gemacht
darüber schaut man die wechselwirkungen
ja auch nicht oder frau bei ihnen nun
auch da geht es um dieselben fragen
wie gut versteht man das genom der
jeweiligen organismen und welche risiken
führt man bei solchen experimenten in
ihr genom und in die keimbahn 1
die frage der sicherheit und der
notwendigen vorsichtsmaßnahmen stellt
sich nicht nur in bezug auf menschen
sondern gleichermaßen bei allen
organismen besonders beunruhigt da ist
nicht unbedingt die wechselwirkung mit
anderen gegenden man kann ja sagen wenn
ich eine mutation traube die schon eine
furchtbare krankheit führen
in meinem leben wenn wir nicht als
tanzendes zu den nicht kernkraft eine
mutation weiß ich dass diese mutation
funktion nicht in menschen
aber das problem ist diese hier bewährt
haben die oft folge perfekte dass diese
schere programmieren ihren dort zu
schneiden aber es gibt eben drei
milliarden solche buchstaben im genom
und wir wissen von experimenten in
zellen und ihren dass man oft dann
schnitte bekommen an anderen stellen die
dann auch verwendet werden und die
effekte von dessen wissen wir eben nicht
und das ist sicher auch bei diesen
zwillingen jetzt passiert und das ist zu
sagen was mich am meisten würde also ein
meer des wissens einerseits aber auch
einen ozean des unwissens der dahinter
liegt das nicht als laie ein wenig
verstört eine verständnis frage ist
einerseits ist es so und sie schreiben
das auch an ihrem wunderbaren buch wenn
man das genom eines individuums sieht
kann man so viel gar nicht über dieses
individuum sagen wie es aussieht wie
sich verhalten wird welche eigenheiten
es hat andererseits scheint es möglich
durch sehr gezielte einschnitte sehr
viel an einem wesen zu verändern also
einerseits eine blindheit was das
gesamte genom angeht andererseits die
spezifische fähigkeit sehr wirkungsvoll
zu greifen wie erklärt man diesen
scheinbaren widerspruch ist es so sein
dass man hat enorme fortschritte gemacht
in den letzten 30 jahren in denen das
man assoziationen studie zwischen
menschen mit einem gewisse krankheiten
und danone und sucht genetische
assoziation wohnen
man sieht in genau was haben die
menschen gemeinsam werden diese
krankheit leiden
im unterschied zu den anderen sodann
verstehen und in manchmal findet man
dann ein einziges gehen die dafür
antworten jetzt beispielsweise dieses
hiv immunisierung es gebe genug den
meisten soll durchaus sorgen
krankheiten die viele menschen
befürchten schon blut diabetes ja das
ist ein bisschen ruf zum beispiel für
görlitz aber beruhen auf sehr viele gene
das ist nicht nur eine position die man
daran so wusste ich jetzt hin
die frage einerseits wissen wir sehr
wenig einerseits müssen wir speziell
gaddafi nutzt das wenn wir aber den
anderen weg gehen um nicht von der
krankheit zu einem genommen und sondern
wir schauen uns einfach das genom abend
und sorgen was kann ich jetzt sagen den
buddhisten in der widum krankheits
neigung verhalten aussehen
dann sind wir unglaublich schlecht aber
sogar sachen wie hautfarbe oder
wallfahrer ikonen windeln zu 70 prozent
korrekt woher zahlen aber ich sagte
gerade malaria malaria wäre dann einfach
wo man sagen würde vielleicht wissen wir
doch wo man schnippen muss und das ist
ja eine krankheit von der mehrere
hundert millionen vielleicht sogar
milliarden menschen betroffen sind
aber jena ist es da nicht geradezu eine
pflicht ein wenig zu schnippeln
malaria ist ein interessantes beispiel
obwohl wir durch aus dem mittel und wege
dazu gehabt hätten
sind wir an der aufgabe gescheitert die
umweltbedingungen so zu verändern dass
diese krankheit überall ausgerottet sein
würde
ich sehe eine pflicht zur prävention und
zur behandlung der
malaria erkrankten menschen nicht aber
die pflicht ins genom einzugreifen
es gibt hier zwei punkte erstens wissen
wir wie gesagt nicht dass wir es können
selbst wenn wir genau wissen welches
gehen für malaria verantwortlich ist und
wer es herausschneiden wissen wir nicht
ob wir damit etwas anderes auslösen
vielleicht sind diese menschen dann
anfällig für eine andere vielleicht noch
schlimmere erkrankungen über die wir
dann keine kontrolle mehr haben
das allein reicht schon für einen
übungsabbruch ja weil ich nicht weiß was
ich tue ich versuche mit sehr
komplizierten mitteln ein problem zu
lösen das sich mit sozialen
präventionsmaßnahmen hätte verhindern
können
das ist nicht zu rechtfertigen dann gibt
es aber bei der malaria diskussionen
darüber nicht das menschliche genom
sondern die gene der mücken zu
manipulieren
das ist auch für mich eine interessante
frage sollen wir die umwelt so verändern
dass wir mitten produzieren die malaria
nicht mehr übertragen können hier fällt
mir die antwort nicht so leicht wie beim
menschen
diese interessante grenze was wir bei
tieren erlaubnis fähig sind und beim
menschen nicht mehr auf die werden wir
noch eingehen bleiben wir mal kurz noch
bei menschlichen genom sie frau war
jener haben wie viele andere menschen
mittlerweile teile ihres genoms
ermitteln lassen
und sie sagen sogar ich habe es in die
öffentlichkeit gestellt ich hab es der
forschung öffentlich einsehbar gegeben
keinerlei bedenken dass da etwas über
sie heraus käme was wir vielleicht
lieber für sich behalten würden
tatsächlich habe ich es nicht öffentlich
gemacht
aber sie würden das auto aber ich habe
gesagt dass ich die daten der forschung
zur verfügung stellen wird
ich hatte natürlich auch meine bedenken
hat es hat mir noch niemand angeboten
mein ganzes genom zu sequenzieren
vielleicht hätte ich mich an sie wenden
sollen also bin ich über eine
privatfirma gegangen
viele kritisierten damals die
kommerziell verfügbaren angebote nicht
so sehr wegen einer möglichen verletzung
der privatsphäre sondern weil man
dadurch unliebsames über sich
herausfinden könnte und aus angst den
ärzten die türe einrennen würde
ehrlicherweise habe ich es aus neugier
gemacht
ich schrieb damals über das thema und
wollte herausfinden ob solche
informationen einen verrückt machen oder
für den rest des lebens beruhigen und
die art der information ist ja wie sie
sagen wir sind ein bisschen schnee blind
wenn wir so ein individuelles genommen
sehen man weiß gar nicht so viel sie
hätten vielleicht gar nicht sagen können
dass frau war jener braune haare hat und
die und die größe hat das kann man alles
nicht sehen und sie sagen auch von sich
selber und sie sind ein mensch der sehr
viel über genau weiß wollten sie das
nicht wissen haben es bisher auch nicht
getan
ja das ist nicht ganz behaupten ist
tatsächlich auch aus vielen aspekten
nicht angeschaut meinte nur es ist auch
so dass für viele sachen die mich
vielleicht beunruhigen würden
krankheiten die ich bekommen könnte
haben wir sehr wenige aussagekraft von
was wir wissen und für manchen sachen
die vielleicht sehr unangenehm ist dann
wir für alzheimer wenn man homo zu gut
ist über diese varianten also beide
kopien sowohl von mutter als vater
dieses risiko varianten an hat man
tatsächlich viel höhere risiko dafür
aber wir können gar nichts tun dann
gegen so warum soll ich das wissen
es heißt auch nicht dass ich jemals als
seien wir bekommen habe was kann ich da
machen kann zu sorgen nichts machen um
es vorzubeugen
die gerne mal ein beispiel nennen von
einer person einer sehr bekannten
angelina jolie die von sich weiß dass
sie an brustkrebs wahrscheinlichkeit
hatte auf ihrem grund ihrer genetischen
anlagen die sich beide brüste abnehmen
ließ weil sie sagte sie könnte es vor
ihren kindern nicht verantworten
man kann etwas tun aufgrund dieser
information und gewisse menschen tun ist
weil sie es für geradezu ihre pflicht
halten präventiv einzugreifen
sie verwenden das wort pflicht sehr oft
[Gelächter]
ich sehe das anders
die informationen die ich erhielt war
naturgemäß nicht besonders
aufschlussreich aber es hätte mich
interessiert mehr zu erfahren
manche menschen möchten nichts von
dingen wissen gegen die sie nicht tun
können andere und zu denen gehöre ich
schon es gibt hier kein gut oder
schlecht kein werturteil man sollte hier
alle freiheiten haben das so oder so zu
sehen und wählen können
was die pflicht zur prävention betrifft
ich glaube wir haben in einem gewissen
sinn die pflicht ein gutes leben zu
führen
aus verschiedenen gründen ich stehe als
mutter als freundin als bürgerin in der
pflicht mich um ein gutes leben zu
bemühen
man kann also durchaus argumentieren
aber wie sie wissen gilt es bei den
pflichten ihren geltungsbereich genau
abzustecken
soll man bei der vorbeugung so weit
gehen dass man verpflichtet wird gesund
zu leben nicht nur den schritt zur
mastektomie zu machen sondern auch sich
gesund zu ernähren täglich sport zu
treiben nicht zu rauchen zu trinken all
das was bekanntlich zu einem gesunden
lebensstil gehört
interessant es gibt diesen philosophen
imperativ erkenne dich selbst erst genom
scheint dann schon eine art spiegel der
selbsterkenntnis werden zu können dass
man mehr informationen über sich hat als
man vielleicht vertragen und für sich
selbst auch verarbeiten kann eine
information aus ihrem genehmigen könnte
herr p wahrscheinlich schon sehr gut
nutzen
er könnte nämlich sagen wieviel
neandertaler in die ihn steckt wie viel
näher an der tat in jedem von uns steckt
das kann man schon sehen angenommen oder
genau sowas will herausgefunden haben
dass werden ihre genetische wurzeln
außerhalb afrika ist dann abends
traumatisierung gefährt 1 bis 2 prozent
des genoms kommen von lernen und zwar
unterschiedliche stücke wie werden ich
weiß bei unterschiedlichen menschen so
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich sie und sie
unterschiedliche sagt man so ja ich
würde sagen 1 bis 2 mm vielleicht drei
hat man den erkenntnisse darüber was
diese speziellen sequenz die meisten
noch in sich tragen für funktionale für
wirksame wirkungen zeitigt wie lange
mehr und mehr darüber fast jedem monat
erscheinen helfe es dazu viele davon hat
tatsächlich mit risiko oder schutz gegen
krankheiten zu tun das ist auch weil
viel kommt von der medizinische genetik
es gibt varianten ziemlich häufig sind
hinaus sind zum beispiel hohe risiko für
typ-2-diabetes n typ von zuckerkrankheit
in einem hohen auto bekommt es gibt also
viele hautkrankheiten zum beispiel ist
das risiko rielle sachen aber auch
sachen wie der kreation oder neigung
sondern auch zum beispiel es gibt auch
varianten die tatsächlich vorteilhaft
sind viele immer immunsystem gibt eine
variante die von einem
von der tollen aussehen kommt im team
wird die es erlaubt am hohen höhen
ladung zu leben wo wenig sauerstoff ist
gibt in der atmosphäre
aber wenn ich jetzt meine fantasie
spielen lassen mit christa könnte man
sagen ich will einen sehr
leistungsfähigen 10.000 meter läufer dem
schnitzel ich dieses gen für die blut
sauerstoff regulation und dem anderen
der nicht zuckerkrank werden soll dem
schneide ich das andere dar ein spiel
nicht da oder ist das eine perspektive
die sich öffnen könnte
da haben wir genau alle diese vorbehalte
die wir jetzt besprochen haben nicht
dass wir morgen nicht wissen was der
andere effekte wie im genom haben dass
wir auch nicht wissen wie funktioniert
diese varianten wenn wir dann in einen
anderen umwelt leben
wir wissen ja dass zusagen krankheiten
oder andere effekte von genen ist ein
zusammenspiel sich in diesem genetischen
varianten und der umwelt in dem wir
leben
wieso ist eigentlich eine genetische
variante zu 25 für seine teufel gleiten
gekommen die zu diabetes führt heute
eine gute spekulation habe ich dazu
und das ist das was diese variante
führte zu problemen in einem
gesellschaft wo wir fast zuviel ersten
unserem ganzen leben in einer anderen
situation wo wir periodisch hummeln sind
wahrscheinlich dieselbe varianten sehr
vorteilhaft so sollte mir das selbst
verändern wir wissen nicht was uns die
zukunft ist das hat schon was von
spielen in diesem sinne wenn man so will
wenn man ihre forschungen sind dann ist
das einerseits der handwerklich es ist
andererseits sehr biologisch
medizinische ist es andererseits aber an
hantieren mit extrem großen zahlen
mengen mit wahrscheinlichkeiten mit
milliarden von daten
frau werner es gibt ja eine art connex
eine verbindung zwischen diesen
genetischen fortschritten und big data
mit der fähigkeit daten mehr und mehr zu
verarbeiten
sehen sie da die große zusammenkunft die
neue sprünge ermöglichen würde
einerseits big data und andererseits das
genom wissen
[Musik]
die hoffnung ist groß dass wir mit der
verbindung von den einsichten aus der
genetik den analysemöglichkeiten aus big
data und dem wissen aus anderen
bereichen ein besseres verständnis über
krankheit und gesundheit erlangen lange
glaubten selbst die wissenschaftler dass
mit der entschlüsselung des genoms all
unsere gesundheitsprobleme gelöst werden
mittlerweile wissen wir dass es vieles
gibt was wir nicht über das genom allein
verstehen können weil die dinge die uns
ausmachen interaktion mit der umwelt
oder das mikro bio das proteom und
andere aspekte unserer biologie sind
wesentlich für ein verständnis von
krankheit
der eigentliche auslöser für unseren
forschungsdrang ist er meist mehr über
uns zu erfahren und darüber warum wir
krank werden wie wir gesund bleiben und
wie wir alt werden von beta erwarten wir
tiefere einblicke in unser verhalten und
unsere interaktionen mit der umwelt die
verbindung neue analyse werkzeuge mit
den wachsenden erkenntnissen über unser
genom mert unser wissen darüber wer wir
sind
mindestens in bezug auf krankheit und
gesundheit
aufgrund dieser hoffnung fließen viele
mitten in dieses aufregende und
vielversprechende forschungsgebiet ein
fantastisches beispiel für solch einen
gelungenen forschungsschritt ist das was
sie geleistet haben
herr peek sie haben mit ihrem team das
genom des neandertalers weitgehend
rekonstruiert sie sind dafür
preisgekrönt worden vieler weise auch
von der körber-stiftung und wie sie das
gemacht haben wie das in ihrem labor
aussieht das schauen wir uns auch in
einem kleinen film an
in fundstücken wie dieser höhle fördern
die wissenschaftler hunderte von knochen
fragmenten zu tage das rohmaterial zur
erforschung des neandertaler erbguts von
der steinzeithöhle gelangt das wertvolle
knochenmaterial in die reinraum labors
von svante pääbo
hier beginnt mit dem heraustrennen
möglicher erbgut teile aus den knochen
die eigentliche arbeit der beginn eines
sehr mühevollen vorhabens denn in vielen
dieser proben ist nur sehr wenig oder
gar keine brauchbare neandertaler dna
mehr erhalten
doch im laufe der jahre konnte das team
den genetischen schatz aus der
vergangenheit zutage fördern
möglich wird dies erst durch die
aufarbeitung der erbgut fragmente aus
den knochen
dazu werden die winzigen dna bruchstücke
zunächst vervielfältigt und dann wie ein
puzzle zusammen geführt
mit dieser hightech gelang in den labors
eine weitere wissenschaftliche sensation
die ein neues licht auch auf uns heute
lebende menschen wirft aus afrika
kommend treffen die modernen menschen
vor rund 50.000 jahren zunächst in
vorderasien auf die neandertaler und
mischen sich mit ihnen die gemeinsame
nachkommen bilden vorfahren heutiger
europäer
es gibt so vieles was einen daran
fasziniert aber was zunächst ja auch
zutage tritt durch den schlüssigen des
genoms gibt es eine neue weise die
geschichte der menschheit als menschheit
und ihre ausbreitung zu schreiben ist
das richtig haben eine neue generation
davon wie der mensch sich über die welt
ausgebreitet hat liefern dieses 1 nicht
gut war schon da wie der moderne
menschen verbessert habe von der
untersuchung und jetzt lebenden menschen
nicht was dazu gekommen durch diese
arbeiten ist dann dass wir verstehen was
passierte mit dem früheren menschen
folgen wären die tolle in europa die
ihren verwandten in aussehen dass die
nicht völlig ausgestorben sind das die
haben sich gemischt bis 9
liga aus afrika und leben dann wahlweise
in menschen heute wenn man so will und
das szenario von dem wir sprechen das
etwa 50.000 jahre 70.000 jahre her und
da gibt es eine hypothese sie nehmen sie
das nahost szenario in dem die
neandertaler und das was wir heute die
modernen menschen und deren vorläufer
sind sich getroffen haben und sich nicht
nur bekriegt haben sondern sie haben
sich auch gemischt sie haben nachkommen
erzeugt weil wir finden das alle
menschen außerhalb auf weiteres auch in
bereichen wo linie an die tolle gegeben
haben wir hinein papua neuguinea
dann ist sozusagen die idee dass man hat
sie früh gemischt wenn man aus afrika
kommt und wir wissen dass es ne andere
tolle lebten sind hunderte von tausenden
von jahren in mitteln osten so
wahrscheinlich ist eine mischung da
stattgefunden und die afrikanische
moderne menschen haben dann diesem
beitrag mit sich gefühlt wie wissen
inzwischen glaube auch dass man hat sich
auch später gemischt wir sehen dann
sogar die schlechteste hinweise darauf
in europa zb
aber sie sind jetzt griechen
unterrichten an der eth sie sind damit
europäerin und sie hätten eine chance
die mehr miteinander thaler gehen in
sich zu tragen als beispielsweise ein
afrikaner
das ist richtig und was hier an dieser
forschung noch für mich hervortritt der
begriff der rasse der mag falsch und
nicht gebräuchlich seien aber der der
population dass gewisse population ein
erkennbares genetisches muster haben den
gibt es doch schon
nun ich habe durch meinen kommerziellen
gen test herausgefunden dass ich zu etwa
51 prozent aus dem balkan stammen zu 23
prozent von der italienischen halbinsel
hier komme und dass ich 277 neandertal
varianten in mir habe ich wollte sie
schon immer fragen was das bedeutet es
gab auch einige interessante und
unerwartete anteile aus asien und der
mongolei etwa tatsächlich sah ich mich
als eine kombination aus vielem was er
angesichts der griechischen geschichte
nicht erstaunt jetzt gibt es zum
beispiel in amerika und im fernsehen
schaut ein unternehmen das bietet an das
genom zu entschlüsseln und dann sieht
man menschen die sagen ich habe
herausgefunden dass ich zu 13% native
american also indianer den das hat meine
perspektive auch nicht selbst vollkommen
verändert ich muss sagen ich bin da ein
bisschen das berührt mich unheimlich
weil man hat das gefühl dass eine art
von rassismus durch die hintertür wieder
eingeführt wird
ich bin ja sozusagen essentiell indianer
das hat doch auch gefahren diesen
kurzschluss zu wagen war eine gute und
eine schlechte aspekt davon vielleicht
nicht es zeigt auch wie häufig man sich
gemischt hat in der vergangenheit diese
vorstellung von einer reinen raste die
erst vor kurzem sich dem nicht ab ist
offensichtlich falsch es gibt jetzt auch
viele untersuchungen und tausende von
skeletten den ort wo man diese techniken
verwenden um bevölkerungs bewegungen
über den letzten 10.000 ja heute
verfolgen da findet man viel mehr als
wir dachten an das heißt würde ich auch
sagen das sagen
die gene sind zu sagen sehr hoch
gepuscht heutzutage wieso wo ist meine
genetische geschichte eigentlich so
interessant für meine identität auf
unglaubliche ja und das verstehe ich
nicht ganz ich komme aus nordeuropa ich
fahre nach griechenland und gucken auf
akropolis und füge mich sehr verbunden
sagen das ist der ursprung von meine
kultur ruhe von uns architektur von der
empathie
ich fühle mich sehr berührt aber ich
weiß schon dass keine von einem blöcken
körperzonen jeweils in den alten
griechenland wohl aber für mich alles in
der widum und mein empfinden und mir ist
verwendet das gar nicht wie wichtig
griechenland und der alten griechen sind
zeit finde ich das für meine identität
ist sind eigentlich meine gene nicht
sehr wichtigen also den es ist die
kulturelle geschichte
das ist auch nicht wirklich diesen
kurzschluss mein genom ist meine
identität zu vermeiden als viele
scheinen den heute wieder attraktiver zu
finden als früher
ich finde es gefährlich identität über
die genetik etablieren zu wollen
solche versuche sind dank der
technischen möglichkeiten und über die
vermarktung solcher tests weit
verbreitet man wirbt dafür indem man
sagt finde heraus wer du bist
als ob du das nicht selber wisst ist
oder als ob jemand das recht hätte dir
zu sagen wer du wirklich bist so
verliert man die autorenschaft über sein
ich und begibt sich in die hand eines
testinstitut dass viele daten von vielen
menschen hat ein solch
reduktionistischen selbstverständnis
gemäß dem ich die summe meiner gene bin
halte ich für sehr gefährlich
mit blick auf die bekannte geschichte
der diskriminierung aufgrund der
erkannten unterschiede zb anhand der
hautfarbe anhand der religion usw der
diskriminierung rechtfertigen will
findet hier den objektiven beweis für
unterschiede über glauben kann man
streiten
das gehen aber ist das gehen das ist
nicht verhandelbar
das führt uns in gefährliches
territorium
ich bin kürzlich auf etwas gestoßen dass
mich als südeuropäerinnen besonders
betroffen machte weiße rassisten zeigten
dadurch dass sie milch tranken und
übersicht gossen das weiße leute ohne
laktose intoleranz bessere und stärkere
menschen sind
sie untermauerten ein solch unsinniges
menschenbild durch diese einzelne
variante die diesen unterschied
produziert der reduktionistischen ansatz
birgt solche risiken was ich auch sagen
findet dass es gibt sehr viele
einsichten die von der genom vollständig
kommen ist die nicht trübe kommen alle
diese unterschiede zwischen populationen
ist unterschieden häufigkeiten von
varianten nicht die häufigkeit milch zu
trinken zu können ist höher in
nordeuropa ist weil er ein internat in
europa abbauen wenn man versorger jetzt
anhand von den daten wir haben sollen
gesamte genome von 100 afrika
vergleichen mit 100 leuten oder aussehen
das ist der grösste zu sorgen
unterschied dass wir haben es uns
geschichten wie viele varianten denken
sie ist eine absolute unterschied also
so ein typ von unterschiedlich gewählt
vielleicht noch eine runde geschossen zu
haben dass in afrika präsent in europa
gibt keine einzige
wie finden zwölf unterschiede im
innenraum wo 99 prozent eine variante in
afrika ein präsent und das kommt nicht
nur über dem was zu sagen meine alte
verwandten denken und genetische
unterschiede das was absolut ist alle
der hornist seien unterschiede gibt es
auch fraglich
es gibt aber eine antwort auf das was
wir alle sind wir sind menschen
genetisch homo sapiens sapiens sie haben
das neandertal gehen um weitgehend
rekonstruiert kann man denn vielleicht
doch ein bisschen genauer mit dem finger
darauf zeigen wo der schritt zu den
fähigkeiten die wir jetzt hatten haben
im vergleich zu andern genetisch
vollzieht gibt es da einflugschneisen
die sagen da passiert etwas was für
unsere geistige für unsere mentale
entwicklung entscheiden
das ist traum was darüber glaubte finden
in der zukunft mit hilfe von herrn
betont das ist schon jetzt auch das ist
teil des projekts durch sogar finanziert
ist und an der stiftung die blume
stiftung
es gibt bereiche in unserem genom in
europa und aus dem wo man sagen würde
dass statistisch erhalten was wir dann
weiter von lernte 1000 haben und wie es
verteilt ist aber wir finden das nicht
da scheint es also dass man selektiv hat
in der vergangenheit selektiert gegen
diese weiterer ferne tauchen und wir
können eine list ein katalog machen
jetzt von varianten die alle menschen
heute zu ordnen
die wir kennen oder 99,9 prozent von
allen ist den neandertaler haben das ist
aber nichts
diese katalog ist nichts zu groß es ist
so 30.000 veränderungen genau so wir
können alle diese fänden und nachmittag
im computer durch gucken
das problem ist er wenn wir verstehen
gar nicht was benötigen aber natürlich
versuchen wir jetzt da einige
veränderungen die patina verändern
vielleicht enzyme sind wo wir wissen
dass die vielleicht tun die zu
untersuchen
eben mit krieg barkassen ein versuchen
diese veränderungen in menschlichen
stammzellen reinzubringen stammzellen
wir machen keine wellen bis daraus aber
wir die fans ihren dann diese zellen die
dann die neandertaler ähnlich und zum
standorten für eingehen
zu den fünf säulen zum beispiel im
gewebe kultur und versuchen zu
untersuchen die funktionieren ist
einfach sehr fasziniert ein bisschen
unheimlich ein kollege von ihnen hat
auch aufgrund der forschungen die sie
gemacht haben gesagt geben sie mir 30
millionen dollar und ich baue ihnen
schöpfe ihnen kreierte einen neuen
lehrern lanthaler frau war jena ist das
eine gute eine furchtbare oder
vielleicht sogar eine sinnvolle idee
ich denke das ist sensationsmache
ich weiß nicht was das soll im hinblick
auf das ziel unser wissen zu vertiefen
und den menschen gesundheit oder ein
gutes leben zu bringen
der anspruch ist vermessen und das
projekt an sich problematisch wie sie
das hat er überhaupt was gesagt hat war
das gros sprecher
es ist nicht einmal kritische systeme zu
tal und vertretbar
die solistisch wie wir gesagt haben ich
habe mir vorher diskutiert sondern
krankheiten vielleicht heikelsten die
presse die man im menschen aus
wissenschaftliche neugier oder sowas
überhaupt nichts kontaktieren
das andere ist dass es technisch
eigentlich unmöglich ist sondern wir
werden wir dann 30.000 veränderungen
einfügen müssten wir sind meilenweit weg
davon heutzutage dass du machen wir
haben eben diese oft the facts die dann
sich hoch addieren
aber wie soll auch sagen es gibt ein
großer teil des genommen sondern für ein
drittel des genoms das repetitive ist
das besteht auf den ausgegrenzten die
ähnlich sind
diesen teil des genoms beim neandertaler
zum beispiel kennen wir nicht genau weil
wir haben nur kurze bruchstücke hat mir
wissen nicht von welcher kopie von
diesen rapids repetitiven sequenzen die
kommen sie wissen habe dass dieser sehr
positiven teilen des kinos auf wichtig
ist für willi unsere zellen und unser
körper funktionieren so will werde nie
eine ganz genau wissen aber dass es ist
technisch und er tisch unmöglich und 0
sensationsmache drei menschen sind ja in
vieler hinsicht seltsame wesen sie sind
auch deswegen seltsam weil sie ethisch
eine absolute grenze zwischen dem mensch
und alles anderen lebendigen
das was wir hier besprechen wird an
tieren derzeit gemacht sogar höher
entwickelten tieren sogar an affen und
wir haben diese effekte wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe kaum mehr im griff
wie ist das eigentlich philosophisch wie
wird diese absolute grenze
gerechtfertigt wenn die
risikoabschätzung doch eigentlich das
richtige argument die grenze ist sicher
nicht absolut in der wissenschaft
pflegen wir natürlich einen anthropozän
trischen ansatz
wir versuchen in erster linie dinge über
uns herauszufinden
in der medizin und den
gesundheitswissenschaften geht es darum
unser leben zu verbessern
zu diesem zweck benutzen wir bis heute
tieren
wir gehen aber längst nicht mehr einfach
davon aus dass alle anderen spezies und
zu nutzen sein müssen
unser denken und unsere haltung den
anderen spezies gegenüber hat sich
radikal verändert heute sind wir durch
schutz und beziehungs gedanken geleitet
wir machen zwar tierexperimente auch mit
höher entwickelten tieren mit affen
nicht menschen aber zumindest haben
diese spielt sie ist heute eine andere
stellung
man bemüht sich um vernünftige
schmerzgrenzen und alle experimente
müssen ungeachtet ihrer verfügbarkeit
gut begründet sein
unsere haltung den tieren gegenüber hat
sich also stark gewandelt sie spüren
heute eine verbundenheit ihnen gegenüber
das führt hoffentlich zu einem besseren
verständnis über unsere verflochten heid
mit der natur die ja nicht nur aus
tieren
höhere oder niedrigere fähigkeiten
besteht sondern auch aus den pflanzen
den wäldern
wir führen hier ist mein eindruck ein
extrem europäisches gespräch in dem
sinne dass wir die probleme die gefahren
die tabus in den fokus stellen andere
erdteile sind da sehr viel
optimistischer utopischer die sagen das
ist doch wunderbar für die biodiversität
für den schutz von tieren die vom
aussterben bedroht sind von pflanzen die
vom aussterben bedroht sind
all das können wir durch diese techniken
in gewisser weise schützen indem wir es
reparieren
das heißt es öffnet sich nicht noch ein
problem option sondern auch die
möglichkeit sehr viel zu retten und zu
schützen was derzeit vor der zerstörung
bedroht ist jetzt nicht ganz
er ist nicht reagiere von denen wir
mittlerweile das genom haben dass sie es
vielleicht 80 jahren nicht mehr geben
und dann hätte man die in gewisser weise
gerettet und bewahrt
ich bin zu sagen einig dass wir bedrohte
tiere haben die wo sehr viel in die
wieden wenigen die wiegenden vorhanden
ist macht es sehr viel zu sagen zellen
ein zufrieden für die zukunft wo man
vielleicht technologien haben individuum
zu schaffen
wenn einmal ein eine art ausgestorben
ist und wir haben keine zusagen zellen
die lebensfähig sind
dann sind die endgültig ausgestorben
diese technologien wird nicht dazu
führen dass man die in einem richtigen
zähne wieder herbringen kann man könnte
dann kann man sich vorstellen weltkriegs
biotechnologie einzelner eigenschaften
mit einbringen so wenn ein tier
berühmten ethikprofessor in boston ja
sagt man er will man zurück schüchtern
heißt das nicht dass sie wirklich an
mamas sorgen würde viele will vielleicht
auch weglassen oder was man das einfach
denn es würde eine elefant seien diebe
haut ist hier vielleicht maximum
und das ist doch irgendwie eine
maskerade
ich kann mir vorstellen dass mancher zu
werden
das bringt uns zurück zu ihrer frage
über unser verhältnis zu tieren
natürlich kann man argumentieren dass
man so der natur etwas zurückgibt
aber auch in dem fall sind wir es die
darüber entscheiden gesetzt es wäre
technisch möglich haben wir uns dann
überlegt ob ein solches tier in der
heutigen umgebung überleben kann
man scheint sich dazu nicht viele
gedanken gemacht zu haben
im vordergrund steht unsere macht etwas
so furchterregendes großes und
beeindruckendes zurückzubringen
der wissenschaftler wird so wenn nicht
so gott dann wenigstens zum mächtigen
autor des lebens der die geschichte so
schreiben kann wie er will
indem er das mammut zurückbringt oder
malaria oder die mücke ausrottet er
hängt diesem stark in der relativ an
gemäß dem wir den ablauf bestimmen
wir sind oder es ist vielmehr eine frage
dieses evolutionäre geschehen auch das
genetisch geschehen ist millionen
milliarden jahre lang auf seinem weg zu
uns herr p e book ist es eine falsche
einschätzung zu sagen dass wir derzeit
wenn wir über die evolution als
revolution nachdenken an einem ganz
neuen punkt an einem wendepunkt sind in
dem der mensch das übernimmt was
milliarden jahren dann sogenannte
natürlich ablief
ich würde sagen es ist natürlich das
erste mal dass man sich vorstellen kann
könnte dass wir ändern unseren genau
aber wir werden da eine sehr begrenzte
und wahrscheinlich einfältige weiter tun
so viele denken das mitmachen die
revolution läuft ja immer weiter jedes
baby das geboren ist hat 50 bis 150 neue
mutationen dauert jede form von dem
model noch vom vater kommt so die
revolution läuft weiter was immer wir
machen
aus dem meer wieder basteln aber die
fortschritte allein der letzten 30 jahre
die sich ja vielleicht auch akkumulieren
mit manch anderen technischen
möglichkeiten wie big data
die könnten auch dazu führen dass wir
sagen wir sind hier an einem wendepunkt
vielleicht den 26 11 erreicht und wir
können noch nicht mal abschätzen wo wird
in 20 jahren sein werden wenn man die
fortschritte der letzten jahre sieht
hier sollten wir tatsächlich die autoren
seien nicht indem wir das pelzige mammut
zurück bringen sondern in der art und
weise wie wir über diese dinge
nachdenken
sie sprachen über die geschwindigkeit
der evolution
wir nehmen uns angesichts der
geschwindigkeit des technologischen
fortschritts nicht die zeit dinge
durchzudenken
wir reagieren reflexartig und rufen
entweder nach einem moratorium weil
etwas gefährlich scheint und wir nichts
darüber wissen oder wir preschen aus
begeisterung blind voran
keine dieser vorgehensweisen ist
überlegt und umsichtig hier macht es
sorgen dass wir hier sitzen und keine
ahnung davon haben was uns die nächsten
20 jahre bringen
ich würde gerne sagen können wir sind in
der lage gewisse entscheide darüber zu
treffen in welche richtung wir gehen
wissenschaft und technologie geschehen
nicht irgendwo da draußen ohne uns wir
sind die primären akteure darauf sollten
wir heute unsere anstrengungen
konzentrieren
der antrag kann aber viermal länger auf
der erde als die modernen menschen es
bisher sind könnte es sein dass meine
500 jahren aufgrund verschiedener
genetischer modifikation auf uns drei
zurück so schaut wie wir auf den
neandertaler zurückschauen sein kognitiv
eingeschränktes krankes
letztlich dummes wesen sie habe viele
vorurteile gegen die toll was ich meine
ist kann es sein dass wir in einem
schritt zu einer menschen sind der auf
uns so zurückschaut wir wie auf den
wandertag
eines tages wird man sich jetzt
zurückschaue davos ich weiß doch dass
aufgrund von genetischen eingeführten
veränderungen im genom ist aber
natürlich ist man zurückdenken auf uns
als sehr rückständig in der zukunft ist
das ein fortschritt den sie sich
wünschen
fortschritt ist zurück zu blicken und
sagen zu können wir sind auf vernünftige
und überlegte weise dahin gekommen wo
wir jetzt sind
ich glaube an die macht der vernunft das
wirklich wichtige ist dass man beim
blick zurück auf und sagt die haben sich
was überlegt selbst wenn sie fehler
gemacht haben
ich hoffe sehr dass dieses gespräch ein
kleiner schritt auf diesem gedanken
vollen fortschritts weg war ich danke
ihnen sehr dass wir sicher waren rp die
frau war jena vielen vielen dank
nächste woche sehen sie hier in der
sternstunde philosophie einen film über
eine oper die nach dem willen der
russischen justiz nicht hätte
stattfinden sollen cosi fan tutte
inszeniert am züricher opernhaus von
kiril serebrennikow der in moskau unter
hausarrest steht und jetzt geht es
gleich weiter mit einem film über den
pianisten menahem pressler waren sie es
gut und trinken sie weiter
[Musik]